Speaker 1: It is the one year anniversary of the
Donald Trump January six riots in Washington,
DC. Tomorrow, we'll talk about Joe Biden's speech,
in which he very heavily, very strongly blames
Donald Trump for what happened a year ago.
If you can imagine a more. Brain dead.
Ill conceived, dangerous action
than this. Donald Trump last night
on the eve of the anniversary of
the Trump riots, put out a statement
calling for MAGA Nation to quote Rise
up. Think about what they did last year.
And think about the insanity of putting out such
a statement once again. Let's take a look at the
Donald Trump statement that he put out yesterday.
Let's see if we can get zoomed in on this so we
can really take take a close look at its statement
by Donald J. Trump put out yesterday. The Biden
administration's response to COVID is getting
worse every day. Joe Biden said quote there
is no federal solution to the pandemic, but he
then federalized the distribution of antibodies,
and red states are getting the short end of the
stick. That's been widely debunked, by the way.
Although I agree that it was a really bad idea
for Joe Biden to run on fixing COVID and then say
there's no federal solution, then why'd you run
on it? That was a that was a mistake by Joe Biden.
In my administration, we respected the role of
governors to take care of their own states, and
they could request the antibodies and therapeutics
depending on what they needed. That's the way our
Capital C country is supposed to run. Now there's
talk by the Biden administration again about
closing schools and even vaccine mandates for
school children. Remember, this stuff is really
determined at the state level, so the fact that
it's being discussed is whether it makes sense is
very, very different than taking power away from
governors. OK. This is an outrage. And here's the
key line and MAGA Nation should rise up and oppose
this egregious federal government overreach.
This is now you might see this and say, David, to
normal people that wouldn't move them to violence.
We are not dealing with normal people. We are
dealing with people here in Trumpists who last
year committed hundreds of crimes because Donald
Trump said, Let's go to the Capitol. These are
people who have spent the last year terrorizing
school board meetings in places where localities,
local municipalities, not the federal government.
Local officials are discussing masking,
vaccination, remote learning, all these different
things. And now Donald Trump says to these people,
you should rise up, rise up and oppose egregious
federal government overreach. This is the exact
type of weaponization of ignorance and
radicalism that leads to Real-World violence,
and Trump is doing it again on the eve of the
Jan. six riots, going on to say the Democrats
are so incredibly mandate happy. And there is
a discussion about a vaccine mandate for school
kids this year in Detroit. Another Democrat run
places. Our administration did what they said
could not be done. Vaccines in record time.
Remember that had nothing to do with Trump.
Based on technology under development for decades.
But we never issued mandates and I never would.
People should be able to choose how they want to
govern their own health. The federal government
must be reined in and give people freedom to
decide whether they want to be vaccinated or not.
Joe Biden said he would never issue mandates, but
he did it anyway. Like so many other things, so of
course, that's pretty dishonest in the sense that
there's just, you know, Joe Biden is not issued,
just a government mandate that people must
be vaccinated. He has done things in terms
of employment. He has done things in terms of the
Department of Transportation, et cetera. You can
say it's good or bad. You can say it's moral or
immoral. It is not illegal and it is not something
Joe Biden said he wouldn't do. We can debate the
effectiveness of it, but it is a lie to frame it
in this way. So on the eve of the Jan. six riot
anniversary. Donald Trump is doing exactly what
he did 364 days prior, which is to tell lies about
a supposedly authoritarian Democrats and encourage
his followers to rise up to go there. And he's
talking about rising up against the federal
government. That is the exact same thing that they
did on January six, 2021. I'm hopeful that because
I mean, listen, a lot of these Trumpists now have
seen more than 700 people charged for their role
last year in the riots. Because there's a
heavy police presence in Washington, D.C.
My hope is there will be no repeat, although some
of them would love to do it. My hope is there will
be no repeat this year, and so far as of today,
that seems to be the case. I want to remind
everybody Tuesday we will be doing the first The
David Pakman Show Viewer Chess Tournament of 2022.
Tuesday, Jan. 11, 6:00 p.m. Eastern.
All you have to do for now is join
The David Pakman Show Chess Club at
David Pakman dot com slash chess. You'll
need a Chess.com account. It's free. I'm not
selling you anything other than a good time.
We've got some great chess streamers who are going
to be participating. Grandmaster Benjamin Feingold
will be playing international master Eric
Rosen is going to be joining us and streaming
women's feed. Master and scrambling is scrambling
is going to be participating in streaming,
so it's going to be fun for everybody. You'll
be matched up against people of your level,
my level is very low, but it's still a really,
really good time. So just join the club
free at David Pakman dot com slash chess and
then we'll have more information next week.